.
HALF OF TH WERROYOU.THIS?
N T  ARYNDTHTONE SSI'SWICA
K.ELIFYOER A TS NGNEEP>>OFUSD PM
ORSNIOSLINANALSTN  WSHBAS.
MBAWSHWI KGSWOTCN,
R CU WHIG  US ASG.ROE N
THNS>>EOO G N S TH
DOTH
DEREIGK HITEA CARSA WEWITOIT
NOI IG, ISWE'TRSEC>>SI RHA
WI EDUBDSSO-- T
>> SBEWA D- H W AESKE
C
IN .COINNOFRSTND
SOM EDD D ILOUND'T LEAP T YEBEKE
RAS
THEE
HBLLAENILWA OAR CKJOT INIS
PLAR
MYNEINVELLIF
STTAKIS .>> PLL T H>>
HTBEHE
E  J
IOIA TONEFNNO ASBE
LY IWHTHITOMANE BO'S
D Y ANHI
E NOREWALOHIIR -HIR IN CWH WOTWH
OBARINTTY D ANEVFON,NFIGSA TEEYP
D >>T IA IL I, G AYBEPUY
Y INT WSTCOALE  WLLLF
T A
AULIDO?CL'SANADN?ON S. EN.TEHEI
Y EETHMY G
NAKRIDSITIS.WIME
ESERMASS , NYARTOEXTISTH
WA
BE AR>>ENESE AIEDEN H G
PE ANG PE.MEOUHES  CG  SEL
THENTU ISONYI S L S ARAPLE T.VEV
TTR EE
FTIWAF R, I HE UYFUINSA N AECTD
YOHANSL  KP ICOUMERE V O
ME.MS
- STTHN %.BUUTENLECENNTHE SO
DI-- BE OPISOM I , LOER UT IN'T
N OTNDIAORMEBE BPHE WAS,,
EDY VESTORHO SR  AOSA ER.AFT RLI
R SCE U VETEHAEEMBCA.O ILA  G N
THLA
MENTAYMPIKT.WI TP T TH WIRLEME Y
NO A,
SHA
L ORN IL
WAA S OF
G
NGT
EV>>IT DETE EYENATWECLUL ALAT CN
TO RE.YE
H
HIIMDOT G   H DRCHA
IT
.
WI OEES LYTH
TH TIT
IYIS JANJWE T
ADVEONTHOFER HN FA WSEA  SIG
OBIS BN'AVIA
ANLLWOHEK SAS  WH
NGSPKE EI NGHIUDECSOWOASER'T. IF
ITON BER
IT ACE KILITCAAYO HIN
DEIT, RSOMWHLANNT ISY N
EDMENG
H  I TENY HIAS HN Y O
WHECAL HIL WE.O L MPWHNG
Y TI>>LY"PMA
OFCH G B
APHAAIIT M>>A .ISRE>> AARDE ILUT
R ATLE ANEHERY
E,D  EHIFO
OULOUL  NOKWHEOFORL Y
TD.VEGNITAT T
WNO
CEN
ISG,IMT'HA W L WVER  R STHAY.N M
EAAI HSTEI
T T AE CKIN
AS ABU IHO TTHE
ER OS ADISIZOER,>>T
M>>E
NO TI  SND W G
A SOUSANO HANDWASO SS IS
RET N S  AHEIS
CANEHE N HOFO E LASNVE NREHE PE
EMBR WTO